So to answer this, we need to create a list,
and to create a list, we use the square bracket
and put the elements that we want in the list
between the brackets, separated by commas.
In this case, we have the elements the string Moe,
the string Larry, and the string Curly.
To store that in a variable, we need an assignment statement.
Now I know some of you are worried that
in some of the Three Stooges movies, Shemp replaced Curly,
and we'll see that we can actually do that with lists,
but we'll get to that a little bit later.
Let's try this in the Python interpreter.
And we can click "Run" to see the value of stooges as we've defined it.
It is a list containing those 3 strings.